you can't as a society just have people
pouring in one of the things we've been
saying is he needs to go into
non-friendly territory and see what
happens uh he went on Nora O'Donnell
this is this is CBS right on CBS uh and
uh they talked about the immigration
crisis take a look we're in New York
we've heard the mayor here say that this
city is about to go bankrupt because of
the migrants that are in this city you
supported sending migrants to states and
cities in the Northeast why do you
support that well we need to stop the
problem I mean so I'll shut down the
Border I will I will end these bad
policies yes we'll build the wall we'll
lean against the drug cartels I mean
part of it is the drugs pouring in or
killing tens of thousands of Americans
you also have criminal aliens coming
their sex trafficking human trust
there's a lot of stuff but just the
sheer number of people New York City is
an example you can't as a society just
have people pouring in you taxes Social
Services Education Health Care all these
different things it's not the way to run
a country and what's happened though is
because some of the sanctuary
jurisdictions who were very high on
virtue signaling when this wasn't
affecting them have now had to
acknowledge that this is untenable for a
country to operate this way
didn't have to contort himself right is
there anything that he said did you just
hear anything that you did not think uh
that he could accomplish that he said
that he can't accomplish I'm going to
defend the Border we're going to send
the military down there like he's laying
it out and you just have to again look
at the track record what did he do in
Florida is there anything he said he was
going to do that he didn't do you know
quick point on the fentanyl thing when
we were doing our run through earlier
this morning uh Phoenix who's 22 years
old said to me that you know what do you
say five or six people that are either
struggling with or or have died
five or six people that he knows at 22
years old coming from Cali that are dead
because of fentanyl I'm 47. I don't know
anyone that was dead from fentanyl I
think I know one or two people that died
of drug overdoses that I was friendly
with in in high school but there is a
massive massive crisis happening and
we are just going to continue letting it
happen unless we elect a leader a
president in this case who's actually in
charge of the Border it's one of the few
things the president's supposed to do
and will who will do what he says he is
going to do
foreign